uh we'll be looking at oblivious
transfer um which is a a technology that
um involves sending data um such that
only a part of it will arrive and the
sender doesn't know which part will
actually arrive it will be the receiver
choosing what they can
read to give you an example to
Illustrated is a problem where you want
to know who has the most money no one
wants to brag about how much money they
have but they've decided that the
richest person needs to pay the bill for
dinner so now you want to compare who
has the highest amount of money but you
don't want to reveal to the others how
much money you have so they all run a
multi-party computation protocol where
they input their amount of money and the
protocol will spit out the winner the
person with the most money uh but it
won't reveal to anyone involved how much
money anyone has that's a sort of
application that you could do with
oblivious transfer but let's first talk
about uh oblivious transfer itself um
the most basic protocol is called one
out of two oblivious transfer I'm
thinking of two values now in this case
I can think of the two values of these
two cards now obviously you don't know
what these values are but I know what
they are right now you're not supposed
to know this but this card is the seven
of diamonds and this card is the nine of
Spates but you don't know this right I'm
putting them here and I want you
to read the value of one of these cards
but you don't want me to know which one
of the two cards you've read right so
you're thinking of a bit bit zero
corresponding to this card the seven of
diamonds bit one corresponding to this
card the nine of Spades and I'm not
supposed to know which card you're
thinking of so I give you these two
cards and then you open one and look at
them while I'm not looking at what
you're doing right mhm so now now you
know either the seven of diamonds or the
nine of Spades I don't know which one
you know but you know one of them and
you don't know the other right so that's
the sort of physical example of it but
how do we do this with uh cryptography
how do we do this electronically right
we might naively think why don't I just
encrypt the two values I just encrypt
seven of diamonds with key zero and nine
of Spades with key1 and then you can ask
me for key Zer or key one ah but if you
do that I will know whether you were
thinking of zero or of one so that
doesn't work what if I give you both
keys key Zer and key 1 then I can look
at both then you can look at both so
that's also broken right we have two
requirements which is I can rely on the
fact that you can only read one card and
you can rely on the fact that you can
read at least one
card after your choice so in order to do
this we uh can modify RSA a little bit
to accomplish this and this is the sort
of most well-known one out of two
oblivious transfer so let's refresh our
memory on what RSA is there's there's a
video that I did about this topic we
don't need to know all the details
there's really only one important fact
that we need to know so RSA works in the
modular world so to remind ourselves if
we have a number
X
mode let's say
12 what this means is that we divide the
number X by 12 and we are only
interested in the remainder of that in
other words if we have a clock with 12
hours and it's 15 hours well 15 / 12 is
1 with a remainder of three and it's the
remainder we're interested in right so
all the values we'll ever see will be
between 0o and 11 because we're computer
scientists we we like to include zero
there so instead of 1 to 12 it will be0
0 to 11 now RSA Works in this modular
world as well but instead of having a
small number like 12 we have a big
number n and n is a is a really really
big number like a th000 bits nowadays is
already considered to be not enough um
you know every once in a while n will
have to go up um as our computational
power gets bigger um so but let's say
that n is 1,24 bits right so then you
have a a message number n and you're
doing your mathematics modulo n then the
special property that we have for RSA is
that there are two values e and D such
that if you take x to the power e to the
power
D this is
equal to
X modul N now how this property is
created you'll have to look at the RSA
video obviously we have to just accept
this as a fact for oblivious transfer so
one party say Ellis can generate e d and
n such that this property here that
desirable property holds now how can we
use this property for oblivious transfer
I'll draw something called a message
sequence chart to explain the the
protocol so we have two parties involved
Ellis and Bob we're
drawing a line
here and here and this allows us to sort
of visualize the communication between
the two parties if we draw something for
Ellis on the left or for Bob on the
right so on the outside it means that
it's their private information that
they're not sending and if we draw an
arrow from Ellis to Bob or from Bob to
Ellis it means that they're
communicating this information to the
other party so Ellis starts off with two
hidden messages so let's call them
message zero and message one in the
example before message zero was seven of
diamonds and message one was the nine of
uh Spades right um and now Alice wants
to communicate this to Bob but only one
at a time so the first thing she does is
she creates a public private key pair in
RSA right so she generates the N the E
and the D with the property that we just
discussed she keeps the d a secret
that's her private key and she sends n
and e to Bob that's the public key part
n and E are sent to Bob the next thing
she does is she
sends two completely random values to
Bob these are values smaller than big n
but generally quite large random values
let's call them
x0 and
X1 so these are just random numbers that
Bob will receive now B Bob before
anything started thought of a bid right
he wants to read either the top card or
the bottom card so he selects which card
he wants to read and call that bit B so
that's a value he's thinking of now
after he receives the two messages x0
and
X1 he will um select a value XB right so
if he's thinking of zero he will select
X zero and if he's thinking of one he
will select X1 so after Bob receives x0
and X1 he selects a random key
k then with that k key K which is a
secret for Bob he does the following
computation he takes XB plus K to the
power e all of that modulo n he can do
that because he was given e by Ellis so
he knows that value he was given n so he
knows that value K is a value that he
randomly selected and so is B XB is
simply one of these two values depending
on the value of x so he can compute this
and and that value that's a single value
let's call that value V what Ellis can
do is she can take the value V and
privately compute two versions the first
one is P0 which is equal
to the formula she just got which is
v- x0 to the^ D similarly
P1 is equal to
vus X1 to the power
D so again this is something that Ellis
can compute because she's given the
value V she knows the values x0 and X1
because she created them and sent them
to Bob and she knows the value D so she
can simply compute p 0 and P1 now the
final step is where the the magic
happens she sends two values to Bob
which is M Prime
0 which is defined to be m0 + p 0 mod n
and the other value is called M Prime 1
which is equal to
M1 + P1 also mod n and this allows Bob
to then do the final step which is to
compute mstar which is equal to M Prime
of the bit he chose minus
k+ p b and what it turns out is that
this value M Star is equal to m p and
that's exactly what we want right so Bob
at the end of the protocol now knows MB
so to illustrate this protocol let's go
with the bit that you selected right you
selected the bottom card which was bit
one so we have B is equal to
1 and we fill in this value for the
protocol so m0 is going to be filled in
as the seven of diamonds and M1 is going
to be filled in as the nine of
Spades um I'm then thinking of some
crypto values we're not going to ineni
those and similarly for the random
values doesn't need to be this
complicated
um what is important here is that XB
here is of course going to be X1 so
V will
equal X1 plus K to the E mod n then I
will compute p 0 and P1 so what will p 0
be and what will P1
be let's start with P1 because that's
the interesting case so P1 will be the
value V what is the value
V well okay P1 is V
minus
X1 all of that to the power D now we can
instantiate V because we know now
because you chose bit one that it's X1 +
K to ^ e so this is equal
to X1 plus K to ^
e which is the value for V -
X1 all of that to the power D now
obviously X1 - X1 cancels out so what
we're left with is K to the^ e to the
power D more than and that's the whole
Magic of RSA K to the^ e to the^ D was
equal 2 K mod n right so it nicely
cancels out and what we're left over is
a value K so P1 is equal to
K now for P0
this isn't going to work we're not going
to do the math for p 0 because it's not
going to lead anywhere right uh because
the value V is X1 + K to ^ e and if we
then subtract x0 and raise that to the
power D it's not going to have any nice
properties so let's ignore that for now
um so P1 has the nice property that is
equal to K and P 0 does not have this
property now if we look at the final
computation here we see that M Prime 0
is going to be m0 + p 0 that doesn't
have any nice properties because p 0
doesn't have any nice properties but M
Prime 1 has nice properties because it's
going to be equal to let's work this out
M Prime 1 is equal to
M1 plus
P1 P1 is equal to K so that means that
this is equal to M1 minus K if we then
look at the definition of m
star
M
Star is equal
to
m 1 - k + K which is equal to M1 and
that's exactly what we wanted so this is
how oblivious transfer works now the
other question is how do I know that you
can't read the other bit of
information I'm not going to go into the
technical details here but remember that
the definition of P0 was just some
random formula to the power D if you can
work out any random thing to the power D
then you can actually break RSA so the
whole point of RSA is that you can't
work out a random number to the power D
unless you know D which you don't um so
that's that's where that comes from it
the you know there's a lot of technical
details that are very interesting but
that don't fit into this video so now we
have one out of two oblivious transfer
how can we get you know more interesting
versions of oblivious
transfer let's first instead of thinking
about small pieces of information like a
single card what if I want to send you a
file um you know
RSA only allows small messages because
our messages m0 and M1 have to be in the
domain of n right if they're bigger than
n they they definitely can't can't work
um and N is a,2 4 bits so any message
longer than a kilobyte we're not going
to be able to do this what we can do
however is we can take two files file
Zer and encrypt it with a symmetric key
s0 and we can take file F1 and encrypt
it with symmetric key as one I'm now
going to send you both encrypted files
and I'm going to now run the oblivious
transfers on the symmetric key so you
will only know the symmetric key of file
file Z or the symmetric key of file one
depending on your chosen bit and I don't
know which chosen bit that is so that is
how we can send entire files using
oblivious transfer and now the final
step uh which is one out of n one out of
n oblivious transfer so what is the
trick here so we'll do one out of four
oblivious transfer as an example and
after that it will be I think quite
clear how we can generalize this to n so
what we do instead of having two files
encrypted with symmetric keys we're
going to have four files now and based
on your choice you can read only one of
those files and I won't know which file
it is so the first file we're going to
call it file 0 0 for the binary notation
of a Two Bit Zero uh so file 0
0 is going to be encrypted with s upper
zero lower zero
and all of that will be encrypted again
so there's two layers of
encryption with s upper one lower zero
and we do this for the next file
F
01 which will be encrypted the inner key
so that's s upper zero is going to be
zero again because the first bit is zero
but the outer key this time will be as
one because it's the outer key but then
the subscript here will be one because
this bit is one similarly the next up
will be file 1
Z which will be encrypted by s0 is going
to be one because the inner bit is one
and the outer bit is
zero the same is true for the for the
fourth file um in this case both the
inner and the outer key will have Bit
Zero so now now we can do a little tree
of oblivious transfer so I do an
oblivious transfer and you're going to
either select inner
key zero or inner key one so that will
be
s0 0 on one side and s0 one on the other
I won't know which of the two bits
you've selected and that means that I
don't know which one of the two
symmetric Keys you've selected and then
we do the same for the outer
key so you either select at your will uh
S10 or
S11 and this is true in both cases so
that means that at the end you've made
two choices for two bits and this allows
you to then have a pair of symmetric
Keys let's say that you went for Zer one
so that means that your inner key is
zero and your outer key is one so that
means that you have the following Keys
you have keys s0 0 and you have the key
S11 and you can now decrypt file 01 and
you don't have S10 so you cannot decrypt
this you can't decrypt this because you
don't have uh
S01 and here you also can't decrypt it
because again you're missing one of the
two keys of course you can now instead
of having a tree of depth two you can
have a tree of depth three or four or
five and this means that with
logarithmically many oblivious transfers
I can make you select one out of any
number if you then want to select k out
of any number I can simply run the
protocol K times is that the best way of
doing it no uh but it's it's a way of
doing it um so of course there's a lot
of technical details and a lot of
optimizations to be had um but I think
it's really cool that I can send you
some information uh that you can only
read a part of but I don't know which
part so the applications of this we've
mentioned multiparty computation um so
here I want to go into more details
about this later so there's a particular
protocol called garbled circuits and
which is extremely powerful it allows
you to run any arbitrary logic over any
arbitrary input without any of the
parties learning any of the input it's
it's very powerful um and very cool um
but there are other things you can do
with this um another one is private
information retrieval so let's say that
I'm a data storage um and you don't want
uh the people making the queries don't
want the data storage to learn what they
are interested in right um simply the
metadata of people keep accessing the
same file might in itself be a privacy
violation um so there are some
interesting ideas surrounding there as
well this is one of the worst things
that can happen so instead of using a
single input we need to use two inputs
the other input being again Sean maybe
you can tell me reasons why G3 should be
more similar to G1 and maybe reasons
that it should be more similar to G2